the 600 extra weekly unemployment
benefits are officially ending today
for millions of americans lawmakers
though are still struggling to find a
way to keep them going
another 1.4 million people filed for
unemployment benefits last week
and this comes as the economy plunged
nearly 33 percent
at an annual rate in the second quarter
nancy cordes is on capitol hill with
more on this story nancy what is the
latest on the deadlock there
well the latest scale is that leaders
from both sides negotiated late into the
night
trading offers but they left without a
deal and so
that 600 dollar federal jobless benefit
it appears will expire today and that
means that
as many as 30 million americans could
see their unemployment checks
drop 50 to 75 percent
republicans and the white house are now
pushing a short-term extension of the
benefits for
maybe a couple of weeks or a couple of
months as they continue to negotiate the
overall
trillion multi-trillion dollar rescue
package which could include another
round of those
1200 stimulus checks but democrats say
they're not doing this piecemail and
they blame republicans for waiting
months to come to the negotiating table
white house chief of staff mark meadows
said last night that
he is now pessimistic that the two sides
will reach a deal
before the senate leaves for recess at
the end of next week
and once they go to rika they are not
scheduled to return
until september 8th wow so hopefully
hopefully they figure something out very
soon nancy thank you